>> ♪ ♪
>> Laura: WELCOME BACK.
LET'S GET REACTION TO MY
EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW WITH RUDY
GIULIANI FROM OUR OWN ALL-STAR
PANEL.
EARL, BRET BAIER IN NEW YORK
TONIGHT.
THE AUTHOR OF THE HUGE NEW SOON
TO BE BEST SELLER "NEW YORK
TIMES," 3 DAYS IN MOSCOW.
RONALD REAGAN AND THE FALL OF
THE SOVIET EMPIRE.
AND FORMER WHITEWATER COUNSEL,
SAL.
SAL WHAT DID YOU TAKE AWAY FROM
THAT INTERVIEW WITH RUDY?
>> WELL, I LOOK AT EVERYTHING
LIKE THIS AS AN INTERVIEW AS THE
PERFORMANCE LEVEL AND THE
SUBSTANTIVE LEVEL.
AT THE PERFORMANCE LEVEL, HE DID
A VERY GOOD JOB.
THIS IS WHAT HE SHOULD HAVE DONE
FROM THE BEGINNING WHEN HE WAS
ON SEAN'S SHOW.
HE WAS MORE POLISHED.
HE KNEW MUCH MORE.
THAT WAS VERY GOOD.
MANY OF HIS STATEMENTS WERE
INCORRECT.
SOME OF THEM WERE PREPOSTEROUS
AND SOME WERE JUST ARGUMENTS AND
OPINIONS.
THERE IS NO WAY THAT THE PERSON
UNDER INVESTIGATION OR HIS
ATTORNEY GETS TO SAY IT'S BEEN A
YEAR, THAT'S TOO MUCH.
IN TERMS OF PERFORMANCE, I
THOUGHT HE DID PRETTY WELL.
>> Laura: LET'S PLAY THE FIRST
SOUND BITE FROM THIS INTERVIEW,
THE QUESTION OF WHETHER THE
PRESIDENT HIMSELF CAN BE
INDICTED.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THE SAME REASON THEY CAN'T
INDICT HIM, THEY CAN'T ISSUE A
SUBPOENA TO HIM.
REMEMBER CLINTON OPPOSED A
SUSPECT AND THEN HE COMPLIED.
HE DID NOT GIVE UP HIS
PRESIDENTIAL PERROGATIVE.
HIS ADMINISTRATION WROTE A MEMO
SAYING HE COULD COULD NOT DO
THAT.
BRET, I WANT TO GO TO YOU.
A JUDGE SAID WHEN MUELLER'S TEAM
WE WON'T INDICT THE PRESIDENT
BECAUSE WE WILL STANDBY THIS
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ADVISORY
OPINION THAT YOU CAN'T INDICT A
SITTING PRESIDENT.
NAPOLITANO SAID THIS WAS A 1999
OPINION.
IT WAS NOT BINDING.
IF MUELLER WANTED TO CHANGE HIS
APPROACH ON THAT, HE COULD.
WHICH I FOUND INTERESTING.
>> THAT WAS A FASCINATING PART
OF THE INTERVIEW.
RUDY IS HANGING ON TO THAT, THAT
THE TEAM TOLD HIM ABOUT THAT THE
INDICTMENT AND STAYING TO THE
GUIDELINES FROM BACK IN THE
CLINTON YEARS.
HIS ANSWER SUGGESTED THEY ARE
GETTING READY FOR A FIGHT.
WHETHER IT'S LEGITIMATE AND HOW
THEY COULD FIGHT IT IF THEY
DON'T WANT THE PRESIDENT TO SIT
DOWN WITH THE GUIDELINES THEY
SET UP.
>> Laura: SAL, YOU HEARD HIM AT
THE END.
LET THEM PUT ON THE TABLE WHAT
THEY HAVE.
WE DON'T THINK THE GROUND ARE
LEGITIMATE AND WE WILL TAKE THEM
TO COURT ON THESE ISSUES.
HE SAID WE WILL RIP IT APART AND
RIP THEM APART.
ONE UP'SMANSHIP ON THE THREAT.
WHAT ABOUT THE SUBSTANCE OF THE
POINT ON THE SUBPOENA?
>> OH, HE IS COMPLETELY WRONG.
THE FIRST SUBPOENA ISSUED AND
SERVED ON A PRESIDENT WAS BY
JOHN MARSHAL ON THOMAS JEFFERSON
IN 1807.
A SUBPOENA WAS SERVED ON MADISON
AND WE KNOW ABOUT THE SUBPOENA
SERVED ON PRESIDENT NIXON AND
THE SUPREME COURT RULED THE
PRESIDENT HAD TO OBEY IT.
HE IS WRONG.
THE OPINION ONLY TALKS ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT YOU CAN INDICT A
PRESIDENT.
PRESIDENT CLINTON DID NOT FIGHT
THE SUBPOENA FROM JUDGE STARR.
HE ASKED US TO WITHDRAW IT AND
SAID HE WOULD COME IF WE DID.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
WE DON'T KNOW IF HE WOULD HAVE
FOUGHT IT.
I DON'T THINK HE WOULD HAVE
IF HE IS SUBPOENAED AND INVOKES
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE, PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND THE COURT RULES
AGAINST HIM, HE CAN SAY LIKE
ANDREW JACKSON SAID, YOU MADE
YOUR LAW, NOW SEE IF YOU CAN
ENFORCE IT.
THE SUPREME COURT SAID TWICE
THESE ORDER VISIT TO BE OBEYED.
HE COULD SAY I AM THE PRESIDENT
AND I WON'T DO IT.
THEN WE WOULD HAVE A
CONSITUTIONAL CRISIS ON OUR
HANDS.
>> Laura: BRET, I BROUGHT UP THE
ISSUES OF STAFFERS.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL BROUGHT IN A
NUMBER OF THE FORMER STAFF OF
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
WATCH.
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT ANY
OF THE FORMER TRUMP WHITE HOUSE
STAFFERS?
HOPE HICKS' NAME WAS THROWN
AROUND WORKING WITH DON JR. ON
THE STATEMENT ABOUT THE TRUMP
POWER MEETING.
ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT HER
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL?
>> GOD THAT WOULD BE REALLY
CHEAP.
IF THEY DID THAT TO HER, A
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WOULD HAVE TO
STEP IN AND ACT.
IT WOULD BE TOTAL INJUSTICE.
>> Laura: BRET?
>> BUT LISTEN, YOU HAVE JIM
COMEY WHO TOLD ME HE DID NOT
KNOW WHAT THIS WHOLE THING ABOUT
MICHAEL FLYNN WAS.
LAWMAKERS SAYING HE TOLD THEM
THAT THE FBI AGENTS DIDN'T
BELIEVE THAT FLYNN WAS LYING BUT
THE SCREWS WERE PUT ON FLYNN AND
HE PLED GUILTY.
HE MOVED FORWARD.
YOU CAN IMAGINE THE SCREWS BEING
PUT TO A LOT OF OTHER STAFFERS
WHO HAVE DONE INTERVIEWS.
I THINK THE POLITICS OF THIS IS
INTERESTING.
I CAN SEE THE COMFORT THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS IN RUDY
GIULIANI BEING A FIGHTER FOR
HIM.
THEY MAY HAVE MORE AMMO SOON AS
THIS IG-REPORT IS EXPECTED TO
COME OUT SOON.
MICHAEL HOROWITZ MAY HAVE
DETAILS WE HAVE YET TO REVEAL.
>> Laura: BRET, ON A DIFFERENT
TOPIC.
PRESIDENT REAGAN FOR WHOM I
WORKED.
GOES OVER TO MOSCOW IN 1988 AND
GAVE A SPEECH AT MOSCOW STATE
UNIVERSITY.
THIS THING ABOUT KOREA AND
WHETHER THE SUMMIT WILL HAPPEN.
I WONDER IF THERE WILL BE A DAY
WHEN WE COULD HAVE PRESIDENT
TRUMP GO TO NORTH KOREA OR A
UNIFIED KOREA AND SPEAK TO A
MIXED GROUP OF STUDENTS FROM THE
NORTH AND SOUTH.
THINK ABOUT HOW WILD THAT WOULD
BE.
NOBODY PROBABLY THOUGHT IT WAS
POSSIBLE FOR REAGAN TO GO TO
MOSCOW.
>> DEFINITELY NOT.
THE PRESIDENT WAS TALKING ABOUT
ANTI-COMMUNIST FEELINGS AND
THOUGHTS.
EVEN BACK WHEN HE WAS THE SCREEN
ACTOR'S GUILD PRESIDENT AND THEN
DELIVERED A SPEECH IN THE HEART
OF COMMUNISM IN MOSCOW.
IT'S POSSIBLE.
IT'S TOUCH-AND-GO WITH THE JUNE
12th SINGAPORE SUMMIT BECAUSE